大家好,这里是穷色几欲,一个留不开钱的频道
最近一本新书上架,一位股市投资人今年才31岁
但他一年在市场的交易量就高达3000亿元
光是绞交的证交税就将近2亿
是一般人几辈子也很难赚到的数字
这位传奇交易员就是网络论坛上相当有名的巨人杰
巨人杰从17岁踏入股市,投资年龄已达14年
庞大的交易规模
让他成为主以撼动股价涨跌的主力
而他也将自身的投资经历
写成《巨人思维》这本书
本信片就要聊聊这本书的内容
巨人节出身小康家庭
父母亲都是学校老师
但他小时候并不是热爱学习的那种乖学生
从小学开始
他考试就经常掉车位
不过上了高中以后
他遇到一群特殊的年轻老师
这些老师并未受限于传统框架
因此让成绩不好的学生
迎来改变的契机
其中一位数学老师
为了让巨人节好好停课
允许他在课堂上吃零食
条件是要坐在第一排专心听讲
身为吃货的他
迅速燃起对数学的热情
最终顺利考上中原大学应用数学系
之后更进到政治大学统计研究所
17岁那年
巨人节迎来人生第二大改变
父母带他到券商开户
触发他对投资的兴趣
对当年的巨人节来说
跟着股票点位上下起伏模拟下单
就像是一场激烈的电玩游戏
不久后
他把从小到大的红包钱
加上父母亲帮存的定存
凑成一笔投资本金
拿着50万正式踏入市场
然而实践并不容易
巨人杰意识到
要从股市获利比想象中还难
这几年的交易
他都没有成功扩大本金
直到2015年才遇到转捩点
在此之前
巨人杰因为拥有数学系的背景
他试图找出破解股市的公式
但受作后他沉浸下来
趁着备考研究所的时间
在补习班上遍各种课程
包括产业分析
不动产经济
企业并购
总进到财务工程
每天早上8点起床
半夜两三点才入睡
而投资功力也在不知不觉间升级
时间拉回2015年
当时台股突破1万点
但很快就开始下跌
据人杰认为
在股市飙涨到高位之前市场大量经常追高因此短期内很难再创高点于是他决定做空结果在高点过后一个月股价跌了将近500点此时他观察到另一件事
那就是中国股市也开始重挫
恐慌情绪蔓延到台股
并在同年8月底
创下当时的历史跌幅记录
然而巨人节基于过往的观察
研判市场处于不正常的恐慌状态
于是他全数回补
加上买进金融股
来回操作
让他赚进不止一桶金
虽然对于很多少年股神来说
一桶金不算大钱
但这次经验让他体会到
风险报酬不对等的重要性
而这个观念日后更成为
他投资理念的基石
经历过2015年的获利
巨然杰逐渐开始拓宽投资战场
第一步是台指期与台股当中
他会观察国际股市与新闻
原因是台股
很容易受到美国等主要国家的影响
另外他会观察全职股的走向
毕竟全职股对大盘有很大的影响
第二是海外期货
由于台股与台纸期的波动
比国际市场要小
因此巨人街在白天操作台股之余
也会试着投资日经指数
等台股收盘以后
他还会交易欧股期货
到了晚上换美股登场
此外有波动更大的商品期货
包括清原油与天然气等类型
同时他也发现
海外期货的观测重点跟台湾市场不同
外国投资人相当重视各种经济数据
例如非农业就业指数
物价指数与利率等
这也迫使他将脑袋再度升级
他投入的第三个战场是选择权
最后则是股票期货
2017年的台股
投机风气相当兴盛
股票期货的流动性也因此增加
据仁杰当时采用的策略
是利用股期较低的手续费
执行不对就跑
对了就报的战术
同时他还发现
当年股票与期货的撮合制度不同
因此存在套利空间
到了某一天
巨人杰意识到自己的股票
集货的成交量
已占据市场上最热门标的五成
但他也知道
当时这些策略
一不小心就会被造势者狙击
加上股企的流动性不如股票
于是他再度把重心转回股票市场
正好又一个大事件降临
那就是新冠疫情
2020年3月
美股出现数次熔断
平均每天的震荡幅度将近6个百分点
创下历史记录
巨人杰回顾当时的操作策略他不是依靠什麼深奧的分析而是順勢操作進場赶到不对劲就停损一旦赚钱就续爆由于当时全球股市几乎都在剧烈波动
对他这种高阶投资人来说
正是赚钱的好时机
当时的巨人节完全化身交易狂人
每天早上七点起床
一路交易到下午抬股收盘
小睡一个小时
他继续操作欧洲期货
一路到七点才休息
一个半小时后继续坐上电脑桌
熬餐到半夜4点多
期间的吃喝全靠妻子协助
却连上厕所都要百米冲刺
只在这段期间
他的资产与税额因此暴增到亿元等级
在这波热市期间
许多人都有赚到钱
却因为股市快速反转而回土获利
但巨人节却在分析局势后
开始布局多单
虽然账面上也曾蒙受不小的亏损
但之后长期走势符合他的预期
这一波又赚进几千万元
在这段投资过程中
巨人杰的每日成交量不断放大
当冲手法也出现变化
最初他不限标的
但考然到市场的未纳量
逐渐转到只瞄准全台成交量
排名前几高的股票
同时他也化身散户口中的主力
像在2021年台股市场成交爆量
其中有好几天
成交值排行最高的个股
买卖合计成交量最高的都是巨人杰
这也为他创造出
一般散户难以复制的优势
强大的资本与实力
让巨人杰成为投资人眼中的传奇人物
不过他也透露
自己还是会看错走势
除了靠试单调整方向
他的投资策略背后隐藏两大重点
第一是拉高赚赔比
多数人在刚踏入当冲领域
都会想要追求高胜率
但问题是股票有赚有赔
不论胜率再高总会有赔钱的时候
因此巨人杰认为应该要控制风险
同时拉高赚钱的上限
至于实际的操作手法
他建议透过加减码
调整持有部位
针对台股来说
投资人介入成交量较大的个股
每次赚到的价差
可能只有2-3个百分点
但如果善用减码控制损失
加码放大获利
就能降低预测胜率
背后的不确定性
第二是掌握风险报酬不对等的机会
书中以等红灯过马路来说明这个概念
在灯号转换时多等一下
就能避免事故风险
而赚赔比与报酬也是同样的道理
探用到投资领域书中提到一个经典的布局策略那就是观察企业的商品发布消息例如美国最大的国际消费电子站官方都会提前公布展览主题
期间不太会有厂商宣布利空消息
因此就有很多投资人
会调查年度各大展会展期
来布局进出场的时机
不少概念股甚至存在固定的价格波动模式
而这正是可以操作的部分
第三点
炒股没有永生不败的神话
最核心的解方就是分散风险
不过度追求一时的得失
说到分散风险
去年港股行情低迷
但美股持续高升
许多人就透过炒美股获利
而在今年美股开始疲软
又换日股持续高升
所以放眼全球各个市场
总能找到投资机会
据上前面提到的巨人杰
他白天操作台股
同时也涉足日经指数
等台股收盘以后
还会交易欧股期货
到了晚上换美股登场
这便带出下一个重点
聪明的投资人总会在全球范围找寻机会
规避掉单一市场的风险
这里推荐朋友们
一个APP就能交易全球的券商
富途牛牛
最近富途牛牛上线了日股交易
除了日股、美股、港股等正股交易
还支持海外齐全、期货、基金债券等
这款APP功能齐全耗用
界面美观
牛牛圈有非常多的投资教程
与牛友经验分享
非常适合新手投资人
近期富途与纳斯达克成为战略合作伙伴
联手为全港投资者带来更优质的服务
富途24小时每股交易功能
任何时候都可以买卖每股
不用辛苦等时差
对于想做全球资产配置的投资者
这将带来非常棒的体验
当前在富途开户
可向高达1900开户奖励
开户前输入兑换码
更有额外200块的现金券
把握时间成为牛牛用户
体验升级版牛牛服务
当前我们身处大投资时代
市面上许多书籍都在敲人炒股致富
但巨人节的故事
却揭露在股市中
想要靠当冲赚大钱有多么困难
如果不具备同等能力
以及投入研究的决心
或许我们可以思考
是否该继续找寻
更适合自己的投资方法
避免将股市当成赌场
好了
这集的穷奢就到这里
对这个话题有兴趣的朋友
不妨在下面留言
聊聊你们的想法
喜欢我们的话
可以加入频道会员
除了可以使用
可爱的穷奢军贴图
还能支持我们维持日更创作
期待你的加入
拜拜